que juste pour le tour de table parce
que comme dit michel qui fait plein de
bruit michel darif vous avez préparé des
bruits et michel ce que vous pouvez nous
faire déjà une petite petit truc d'abord
comme ça mais c'est pas un boucher le
bonbon déjà par hasard à dynamo chéri
déjà par exemple à kasenyi et s'attache
à donner à la cemac écoutez moi la
bouche d'un rallye j'ai prévu une petite
habitation
je vois ce bal et de chercher loin
c'est techniquement c'est très triste
quand on fait le chômage la france
allait fermer un beau c'est vrai je vais
faire une imitation si oui bah les
himbas trackers on n'est pas là pour
chier des bulles
je peux l'être - banon
c'est isabelle morini-bosc y tourner la
tête
pour le cdh où qu'ils se trouvent et qui
maintenant disent avoir fait on est le
juste pourquoi ferme les yeux on imagine
toi maintenant je lui ai envie de fermer
les yeux quand tu as un dauphin c'est un
dopant les i fo pa chauriens n'ont pas
le cul quand même encore que les congas
lac gilles verdez tranquille allez on y
va non allez c'est bon on ne fait pas
bon je sais bien tout ce qu'on a vu sur
ce match là mais attention je peux le
faire
le fait ça romejko non non non il ne le
fait pas vous ne le faites pas matignon
alors c'est pourquoi
et parce que les mouches ont des dons
merci savais pas quoi dire ça s'émeut
une bagnole et michel tu dois trouver
nous vas-y c'est quoi c'est quoi baudis
plante une charlotte peut trouver aussi
hélas aussi
excusez moi vous allez faire combien de
fois avons-nous centrale c'est une porte
qui claque et binbin allez-y les fermer
le fait
c'est toute attaque
et vous quelle étape au guichet du pôle
emploi vas-y que je te donne un indice
déjà nord a été tabassé un sens que j'ai
appris quand je joue au docteur quand
j'étais puisqu'on en a
big lots joly qui fait ça romejko il au
fait ça se vende à merci bon d'accord
c'est rien avec qu'ils nous servent
annoncé pôle emploi indirect
alors on m'a dit je connais d'arrêt
d'amiens le 25 ans depuis très peu non
oui j'ai aubigny sa coiffure c'est pour
vous que j'ai fait ça rien d'un wayne
batman car oui oui l'école c'est quoi
ces impacts mon coeur et je répondis
d'accord si oui c'est exact en libye
mais c'était une valeur sûre
mais l'espoir de la mêlée
attendez ça mais on a quoi la cua c'est
quoi le délire de la tenue vous aimez
pas vous avez vous allez jouer dans
sissi impératrice mais non pas du tout
c'est d'école un peu d'âme ce qui
revient là c'est vrai vous y connaissez
rien bah ouais bah je cherche le noir cc
c'est bon signe en egypte par exemple
ah ouais bah lésions d'egypte prenons
maintenant sur son mari fait de très
beaux imprimés cet été là c'est une
collection la finalisation avec les
imprimés à la carte ou non il est trop
bien alors dit moi que je
il faut que ça ce bruit non mais tu
crois que tu es venu ici pour nous alors
le cigalon nos bras stephen
la vie est belle je dois faire mes
excuses auprès d'un projet fim pour être
tous les téléspectateurs
je sais pas s'ils passent et jiri pehe
ce que vous m'excusez oui ça va revenir
merci faire si vincent à vienne autriche
on met la balle merci main 126 gala
l'accord soit jamais les égales bonsoir
au québec à la présente a su qu on soit
une bonne couche au fromage bon je vous
disais bon ça c'est tous ensemble
d'accords bêta tous les droits c'était
une de mes préférées tarmac et chouchou
nancy a trouvé la cigale tu dois trouver
sympa je devrais pas intelligent mais
bon parce qu'il ya la mer que nous
appelons un cheval recherche à la 3d
tout le monde avait trouvé vous
comprends pas donc ça pas mieux comme ça
t'en parler normalement
et pour une fois c'est le ton qui monte
sur la bâche
la campagne ne s'est peut-être pas
hésitant bon tant pis pour nous sortir
un personnage comme un film d'horreur ça
vous avez prévu quelque chose alors à la
peau c'est bah oui a parfois fait plus
de bruit que ça bouge qu'avec ses
platines
de qui par la faute de qui qu'est-ce
qu'elle a préparée est ce que je peut
imiter en même temps ouais ben vas-y
foncé qu'à des talents d'imitatrice
merci cha cha filochard on sait il
pourrait peiner dans sa litière